better call Saul recognize one of the
best TV dramas in the medium and what's
cool is that here it is this drama very
highly respected and it stars 2 comedy
guys you Michael McKean I think that's
really neat that you both came from
comedy there's some there's great people
in the show Jonathan bang yes terrific
Lawrence yeah but but hey Michael McKean
spinal tap yeah a turd a Night Live got
me an amazing comedy in his past I mean
Lenny and Squiggy yep and here he is
knocking out of the park with drama he's
so great have you seen it yeah it's in
it and it's amazing and these people
inspire me
just like God Breaking Bad with Cranston
and Aaron Paul speaking of Breaking Bad
there's this Gus fring was this yes
iconic character I'm Breaking Bad and in
fact everyone remembers his last scene
on that show when he walked it yeah just
insane alert yeah yeah fix your tie and
they won't notice the half your face is
gone that was one of those riveting
moments on television your show of
course a prequel and there's been a lot
of fan speculation Gus fring is going to
maybe appear out the writers always do
clever things there's little clues all
over the show visual clues and one of
the things they've done and somebody
worked out the puzzle that the acronym
or the first letter of each episode of
last season spelled out a sentence
Frings back yeah and so I guess I don't
know cuz I really really truly don't
know what's gonna happen in the show
right that maybe this season we will see
Giancarlo Esposito in that great role
again right be amazing that's crazy that
I mean people will lose their minds if
that does happen oh my god you can't
write that into the you can't do that
without having it happen right yeah so I
hope yeah great you really don't know
what's gonna happen on the show yeah I
know I don't want that no maybe they
tell you but you forget oh yeah that
happens from always telling any what's
gonna happen on this show and then later
is like I have no idea
he was stunned that you were coming on
yeah no I don't want to know what's
coming up in the show and I mean it's
fun to just be surprised that's great
that's great then you experience it the
same way ah yes yes and then I do forget
it and I watch it and then I experience
it again like that's great you get
enough concussions and this kind of
stuff is fun you were quite you were
quite the jock in your day
you